my children like to play an age-old game
with me called
why i'll tell them for instance that i
need them to finish breakfast
and they'll say why and i'll say so you
can receive adequate nutrition and
hydration
and they'll say why and i'll say because
as your parent i feel
obligated to protect your health and
they'll say why
and i'll say uh i mean partly because i
love you and partly because of
evolutionary imperatives baked into my
biology
and they'll say why and i'll say
because the species wants to go on and
they'll say
why and i'll pause for a long time
before saying i don't know i guess i
believe in spite of it all that the
human enterprise has
value and then there will be a silence
a blessed and beautiful silence will
spread
across the breakfast table i might even
see a kid pick up a fork
and then just as the silence seems ready
to take off its coat
and stay awhile one of my kids will say
why my brain likes to play a somewhat
similar game
the game is called what's even the point
there's an edna saint vincent malay poem
i've quoted in two of my novels
and will now quote again because i've
never come across anything
that describes my depressive blizzards
so perfectly
the chill is in the air the poem begins
which the wise know well and have even
learned to bear
this joy i know will soon be under snow
i'm in an airport when suddenly i feel
the chill in the air
what's even the point i'm about to fly
to milwaukee on a tuesday afternoon
about to herd with other moderately
intelligent apes
into a tube that will spew a truly
astonishing amount of carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere
in order to transport us from one
population center
to a different one nothing
that anyone has to do in milwaukee
really matters
because nothing really matters
there's no point to the human endeavor
in the largest sense
we will leave no permanent legacy in
this
impermanent universe and our central
lasting contribution to earth
will be that we were the first species
to grow powerful enough
to muck up the planet when my mind
starts playing
what's even the point i can't find a
point to making art
which is just using the finite resources
of our planet to decorate
and i can't find a point to planting
gardens which is just
inefficiently creating food that will
sustain our useless vessels for a little
while longer
and i can't find a point to falling in
love which is just a desperate attempt
to stave off the loneliness
that you can never really solve for
because you are always alone
in what robert penn warren called the
darkness
which is you except it's not
really a darkness it's much worse than
that
the writer jacqueline woodson has said
that we need to consider carefully
what we construct as dark and she's
right
when my brain plays what's even the
point what really descends upon me
is a blizzard of blinding frozen white
light
being in the dark doesn't hurt but this
does
like staring at the sun that malay poem
refers to the eyes bright trouble
it seems to me the bright trouble is the
light you see
the first time you open your eyes after
birth
the light that makes you cry your first
tears
the light that is your first and
greatest fear
what's even the point all this trial and
travail
for what will become nothing and soon
sitting in this airport i'm disgusted by
my excesses
my failures my pathetic attempts to
forge some
meaning or hope from the materials of
this meaningless world
i've been tricking myself thinking there
was some reason
for all of it thinking that
consciousness was a miracle
when it's really a burden thinking that
to be alive was wondrous
when it's really a terror the plain fact
my brain tells me when it plays this
game is that the universe
doesn't care if i'm here
[Music]
night falls fast malay wrote
today is in the past
the thing about this game is that once
my brain starts playing it
i can't figure out a way to get it to
stop
any defense i try to mount is destroyed
instantaneously by the blinding light
it feels like the only way to survive
life is to cultivate an ironic
detachment from it if i can't be happy
i at least want to be cool when my brain
is playing what's even the point
hope feels so flimsy and naive
especially in the face of the endless
outrages
and horrors of human life what kind of
mouth-breathing jackass
looks at the state of human experience
and responds with anything other than
nihilistic despair
but of course the problem with despair
is that it isn't very
productive like a replicating virus
all despair makes is more of itself
if playing what's even the point made me
a more committed advocate for justice
or environmental protection i'd be all
for it
but the white light of despair instead
renders me
inert and apathetic i struggle to do
anything
i often can't find a reason to get out
of bed in the morning
[Music]
philosophical questions what's the point
of being alive
what should we seek from life how can we
know what we know
how and where should we seek meaning are
often
dismissed as pointless what's the
difference between a philosophy degree
and a pepperoni pizza
the pepperoni pizza can feed a family of
four
and so on but i think those questions
are
genuinely important because i need to be
able to survive
my mind playing what's even the point i
don't want to give in to despair
i don't want to take refuge in detached
ridicule of unionized
emotion i don't want to be cool if cool
means being cold too
or distant from the reality of
experience
i want to feel what there is to feel
while i
am here you don't choose when your kids
play the y game
and you don't choose when your brain
plays what's even the point
it's exhausting it gets old so fast
listening to the elaborate prose of your
brain tell you that you're an idiot for
even trying
when the game is being played it feels
like it will never end
like you will be in active combat with
your brain
for what remains of your wretched life
but no
no now always feels
infinite and never is
you keep going you go to therapy
you try a different medication you
meditate
even though you dislike meditation you
exercise
you wait your mind keeps playing what's
even the point
and you keep refusing to give into it
battling it with philosophy
and self-help books and religion and
whatever else works
and then one day the air is a bit warmer
and the sky is not so blindingly bright
it's overcast and you're walking through
a forested park
with your children your nine-year-old
points out two squirrels
racing up an immense american sycamore
tree
it's white bark peeling in patches
it's leaves bigger than dinner plates
you think
my god that's a beautiful tree it must
be
100 years old maybe more
later you'll go home and read up on
sycamores
and learned that there are sycamore
trees alive today
that date back more than 300 years
trees that are older than your nation
you'll learn that george washington
once measured a sycamore tree that was
over 13 meters
in circumference you'll read that
herodotus wrote 2400 years ago
that the persian emperor xerxes was
marching his army through a grove of
sycamore trees
when he came across one of quote such
beauty
that he was moved to decorate it with
golden ornaments
and to leave behind one of his soldiers
to guard it
but for now you're just looking up at
that tree
thinking about how it turned dirt and
water
and sunshine into wood and bark
and weaves how it turned nothing
into a place where squirrels play and
you realize
you are in the vast dark shade
of this giant tree and that's the point
i give sycamore trees four and a half
stars